I always say this pay the price today so
you can pay any price in the future pay
the price now okay pay the price so you
gonna make mistakes in your like make
them fast right you're gonna lose a deal
make them lose the deal fast the whole
solopreneur thing I'm gonna do it by
myself I'm gonna work from home that's
it's not even real need motivation watch
the top 10 with believe nation what's up
at 7 my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I wanna see
exploded onto the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from being labeled a DD as a kid
struggling with drug addiction and
almost dying to becoming a motivator a
best-selling author and a top sales
expert with over five hundred million
dollars in real estate is Grant Cardone
and here's my take on his top ten Rose
success volume 4 joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be willing to pay the price
this is the secret of the successful
people this is what I've committed my
life to do it I told my mom when I was
16 years old one day one day I'm gonna
be successful one day one day I'm gonna
be successful and one day I'm gonna help
a lot of people I always say this pay
the price today so you could pay any
price in the future pay the price now
okay pay the price my buddies were
traveling seeing the world and I didn't
have any of those experiences I've had
people tell me
hey you market too much you market too
aggressively take me off your list my
office tells me we hit the list too much
I'm like what's a list bar hit the list
that's what it's for your stay eight
eight eight billion people on planet
Earth
look I've been ridiculed by my peers by
customers and by competition I've been
judged for working too much wanting too
much being too colorful being
inappropriate insensitive and too out
there I'm trying to figure it out I've
been threatened I've been sued I've been
betrayed by friends I've been ripped off
and I've been caught
30 years 30 years 18-hour days not
eight-hour days not 10-hour days not
12-hour days 18-hour days it's been 30
years 30 years it's probably gonna be 30
years for you to doubt uncertainty
insecurities rejection disappointment
judgment it's gonna be 30 years of it
are you willing to pay the price
are you willing to pay the price if
anybody thinks you're gonna be
successful without paying that price
you're wrong
rule number two my personal favorite
meet the world head on you got to get up
you got to get out the amount of time
you spend outside your proximity or
location where you sleep gives you a
better chance to being successful so get
up get out go meet the world head on
folks no matter how bad it is okay you
got you got reputation problems you got
I feel bad problems you got friend
problems you got money problems whatever
the problems are okay try this just get
up and get out go meet the world head on
go meet whatever it is okay you got to
make up to somebody you got to apologize
for something you've done you got to
make up by the damage of of years of
neglect and maybe betrayal and look I've
done all that I've had all those things
where I screwed up over and over and
over again my reputation sucked I was 20
between the ages of 15 and 25 years old
it was like I was doing everything I
could just to damage damage my
reputation okay if it made me look bad I
did it so here today I'm gonna spend 10
days 14 days something like that up here
with that view you can fix anything I'm
proof that you can fix anything anything
can be fixed anything can be fixed but
you got to fix it you got to fix it you
can't just sweep it under the old rug
you got to fix it you got to clean up
the damage you got to pay the price
clean up your debts do what you say
you're gonna do become the most
dependable person in your space come to
go to person oh I can put that person on
stage and know exactly what they're
gonna get for me I can put that person
in the game and I know what play they're
gonna run I can put that person on the
floor and I know they're gonna get it
done be the go-to person okay you don't
need to be funny
you don't need to be entertaining all
the time you don't need to be the person
they're talking about you need to be the
go-to person folks rule number three
commit fully you gonna make mistakes in
you like make them fast right you're
gonna lose a deal make them lose the
deal fast you're not gonna make any
money on the deal make sure the deal is
quick right how many made no money on
the deal this month but it took four
hours
you see most of you in a room
unfortunately you listen to the media so
much you think you're you think you're
you're everything's good you think
you're fine okay because the media has
not exposed the reality on the
middle-class they talk about poverty and
they talk about the rich people and they
never talk about the people in between
the people in between in this country
suffer more than the people in poverty
people in poverty are actually taking
care of people in the middle are
completely ignored I'm talking about the
people that make 200 grand a year and
live up here and still don't have any
money left over
they send their kids to school they got
two BMWs they live in a nice house they
have air conditioned water and heat
right and there's some money so they
send a little bit money to a Keo account
and they think okay we're gonna retire
one day you put me whole one day by the
time you get to use that money you'll be
sold you won't want to use it the only
thing that's gonna change anything for
you and your family is like man what am
I doing here okay you don't need to go
work in another industry you take the
habits you have right now to the
restaurant business the restaurant
business will fail every business is in
disruption right now everything they say
you want to go do you want to go trade
Bitcoin it's gonna take a commitment
it's gonna take ups and downs gonna be a
bunch ups and downs in that crypto play
everybody great yeah okay you want to go
do the real estate game rather than a
card game I'm gonna tell you something
right now man if you don't bring
commitment and discipline and and and
fortitude and persistence in a real
estate game you will get killed in the
real estate game there's no game that
you're gonna win at it doesn't require a
commitment rule number four be
courageous single biggest mistake I've
made in my career was not spending money
it's what put me in a position to be
able to buy real estate because I had
money but I had to buy the real estate I
had to use the money Bradley me to
comment the other day about money money
is not to be saved and hoarded like like
it's no good if you don't use it this is
the problem with Bitcoin when did when
do I transact with it
right I'm sitting on a million dollars
brother Bitcoin right now I can't get
rid of it fast enough I can't go buy
stuff with it so until that that that
situation is resolved right it's why
people don't hoard gold anymore
you don't keep gold because you can't
exchange money is to be used for those
of you out there that are like
complaining about the cost of anything
the truth is that's what that money's
for the only thing the only purpose
money has is to be used and and I was
scared that I couldn't produce more
money so every time I spent money I
complained about it today I'm like
that's the biggest mistake I ever made
should have been spending more money it
wouldn't it take taking me 30 years in
the first five years I should have
borrowed money I didn't have and I
should have spent money that I did have
and I should have gone into debt to do
it to get my brand out there to get it
known the mattress kind your town did it
the car guy in your town did it whoever
spent the most money whoever whoever put
it all out there all the time every day
on every TV radio and the internet wins
in the battle it's not the prettiest guy
okay
[Music]
it's not it's the guy that out advertise
that out Spence yeah it takes courage to
make money rule number five don't keep
your mind wide open take a quick a quick
note out to all of you out there that
believe that an open mind is important
which by the way I agree with you I
agree an open mind is important you know
the old saying the mind is like a
parachute it won't work if it's open but
I want you to add one piece to that if
that parachute is wide open you've
fallen straight to the ground you
understand what I'm saying if it doesn't
open if the mine doesn't open you're in
trouble if it opens too wide you're dead
man bounce it or a dead woman balancing
my point of view is this okay most
people do actually have an open mind the
problem is many people they have a mind
that's wide open with no filters no
gates no protection you listen to
everyone you listen to everyone on
Facebook everyone on Instagram you
listen to your uncle your aunt your mom
your dad when the minds to open you get
too much data and you go into confusion
rule number six work in a team how
important is it to have that team and
and to all those who are watching that
are starting out their teams what would
be the advice that you would give them
yeah well the whole solopreneur thing
I'm gonna do it by myself I'm gonna work
from home that's it's not even real like
I know it's popular you see it on
Instagram and you think some guys doing
something on Instagram that he's not
doing anything posted he posted an image
of his car that he watches on Instagram
yeah okay
okay it might not even be his car by the
way okay he's rubbing out his car and
posted somebody else's car he posted a
picture Edmunds car as he passed up here
Neil
so after he freakin mowed my lawn so
what would I tell you dude you got to be
on a team I mean like like how are you
going anyplace by yourself you live on a
planet with 7 billion people you're like
I hear people say all the time I don't I
you know I'm an extra I'm an introvert
and I don't like people do you live on
planet Earth right ok kind of the wrong
place to intro
so you know people I know people that
can't swim I'm like two-thirds of the
planet is water any jump in this boat I
might want to get your stroke zone no I
mean there's a chance in your life and
that you're gonna need people and you
might need a back stroke right you night
might need to build a hole your breath
and some point so so like I don't
understand why people aren't getting
prepared we live on a planet that is
basically it's got gravity on it it's
got an atmosphere and there's one common
thing whether you're Chinese Hispanic I
don't think Hispanics even up a group is
it my Latino latina okay okay sorry you
got blacks you got white you got
Italians you got all these people right
Koreans you got we've got all these
people but the truth has been economics
bind us all together okay I go down to
the grocery store and there's a somebody
from Korea in there I'm trading money
with that person okay that that is the
exchange you're on a team your team can
be your team that has the goal they want
to go get us to sell hit a target but
part of your team is also the people you
are selling to right and part of your
team is also another team is the
community you live in and another
another team is your church yeah you
know and your family and these are all
teams right and your job and my job I
mean if you want to be all alive all in
the deal your job is to keep all you
need to be a freaking super champion of
all these things right not just one team
rule number seven embrace every moment
how many of you want to make more money
pay attention it you can't make more
money if you don't know what we're doing
here
so the first thing is to decide hey I'm
in the right place those guys had to
walk in that Stadium last night say hey
we in the right place yeah man okay and
then they probably said man we got a
shot here we got the chance to win a
Super Bowl right you came to work today
this is not a Super Bowl unless you want
it to be but I'm gonna tell you
something if you don't get your life
ready right now if you don't start
acting right now like you're the Super
Bowl you're never gonna make one anyway
even when you do make one I mean if you
look at that kid last night what's his
name uh Nick Nick oh he's been sitting
on the sidelines for years overlooked
for years what you do right now every
day even if you hate your job I promise
you I promise you this will happen in
your life if you could learn how to
embrace every moment like this is a
Super Bowl one day you're gonna get
yourself you're gonna get your shot but
you're not your shot will not show up if
you're not ready because even if you
even if it shows up if you're not ready
you won't be able to see it rule number
eight have loftier goals what advice to
have the person did to up there at their
coefficient they're just up there
ambition yeah boy you gotta quit you got
to quit saying nonsense occult stuff
like you know I'm happy where I'm at and
we're good we're all good you know this
is just good everything's good and I'm
better off with somebody and that you
got to comparing yourself to other
people you got to quit talking like the
middle-class like like you've somehow
arrived because somebody and Iran is
suffering yeah you know you're good
until you're not there's nobody watching
that gives enough money to charity yeah
okay everybody watching should be able
to give a million dollars a year to
charity but you can't you know why you
can't you would if you could but you
can't because you didn't yeah you didn't
produce enough because by the way it's
not your money anyway yeah somebody else
gave you the money and you pass it on
most of you like I'm really charitable
I'm really good but you never do enough
why because you never had enough yeah
and so so because you didn't produce
enough because you didn't work enough
because you didn't expand enough so I
would just say to people look have some
loftier goals rule number nine surround
yourself with success so you know every
time I'm having trouble every time I'm
like man I don't think I can get to
where I'm going
I just started looking at the top I
don't look at the bad facts all I do is
I start searching
tell me about wealthy people facts about
wealthy people anything what are they
doing what are they buying it just gets
me out of my problem right it gets me to
think bigger you know the first plane I
bought I bought this plane because I saw
other wealthy people making moves I'm
not an irresponsible person okay like I
have always been a very frugal person
but the frugal was hurting me not
helping me your network is your net
worth how rich you can get has something
to do with who you're hanging with how
rich you can think has something to do
with you who you're hanging with okay
how smart you are has something to do
with your surroundings if you hang out
with dumb people you go end up dumb if
you hang out with junkies you're going
to end up being a junkie you hang out
with criminals I'm not talking about two
people to go to jail I'm talking about
all the people it's your office right
now they cheat their employer and cheat
themselves you hang out with creme
crimps you end up being a Crim
if you want to build a network number
one thing commit to building a network a
network by definition is not if you're
building a new it network is not the
people you're already with it's how do I
add people to my network so number one
you got to commit to building a network
number two who do you want in the
network who is it most of you just go
for more people like you have already in
your network I want new people new
characters new personalities new
thinking new ideas the old adage if
you're the smartest person in the room
you in the wrong room and number three
when you start building this network up
and you start meeting the people ok
number two is who do you want to meet
who who you an add to the Met Network
you go 9,000 people in a room you don't
need to meet all 9,000 you need to meet
maybe a list of 30 or 40 people who do
you want to meet number 3 when you meet
them focus on them not on you it
shouldn't be here's my card I'm a
chiropractor
this is what I do can I give you an
adjustment it should be like who are you
how can I help you what are you doing
where do you live okay what projects are
you working on how can I help you
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips you can do
anything so I was a car salesman when I
was 25 years old with an accounting
degree I was the only accounting degree
car salesman in the state of Louisiana I
hated myself for it I'll make it three
grand a month nobody would hire me as an
accountant one out of four jobs in
Louisiana you couldn't get one out of
four people 25% unemployment and I just
said how do I go from 3 grand to 4 grand
that's all I want to know but I started
paying attention ok who can get me that
money I don't have it who's got it
I needed shoes I needed jeans right I
needed a new shirt I had these white
shirts I'm a car salesman I need a nice
clean crisp white shirts people believe
in me I need some training I don't know
how to talk to people
I hate sales I hate it still hate it
today I've made hundreds of millions of
dollars providing sales of programs to
corporations I hate sales so the fact
that I hated it didn't mean I don't do
it cuz you're only gonna be paid to
waste your whole life you will never be
paid fairly ever so give up the hope I'm
not being paid fairly bullish you will
never ever be paid fairly you're gonna
be underpaid most of your life and then
one day if you're lucky you'll be
overpaid I'm gonna tell you something I
made 4 grand that was the most important
money that I've ever made in my entire
life no money has ever made me happier
than that thousand dollars because that
thousand dollars made me realize I can
do anything
now I've got two very special bonus
grant cardone clips on doing
door-to-door sales and getting your
money mindset right but before that it's
time for the commitment of the day
don't just watch another video you got
inspired by grant today you learn
something I want to know what change are
you committing to making today in your
life or in your business leave it down
the count's below make it public I'm
really curious to say thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
being on planet earth like if you want
to be a good father good mother good son
like a good humanitarian you got to go
door to door there's no other place to
learn it like like the skills that I
learned at I guess I was 30 years old 30
probably for three years I did
door-to-door sales
it was door to business okay I mean
whatever that's called it is a business
yeah one little space so what I learned
business-to-business calling on hey my
name is grant cardone figuring that
pitch out handling my fear handling the
I mean the opportunity to learn this
first of all it's not taught at college
it's not taught in high school it does
not talk there you got to ask why that's
true okay I mean they don't teach
anything in these moc schools informal
education to think the real skills you
need are not done in a ticketed desk
right they're done when you walk up
first of all when you leave your car and
you walk up the sidewalk right like I
don't know these people they don't know
me anything could happen
when they open the door yeah I hope they
don't answer that's the best outcome you
know and all the stuff that you're going
through like some of the most successful
people I know had been on missions and
spent two years on missions I was on a
mission yes though some of them up
single but like I know a guy's gonna
take his company public fishy or
multi-billion dollar company started
from scratch no formal education he was
a mission or missionary work I go out
every day this is how I think about
money I'm running every day for money
I'm going busting my ass man I'm busting
my ass every day I'm busting my ass you
know I'm busting my trying to fill up
the refrigerator take care of the kids
get good education form fuel the plane
up put fuel on the plane fly the plane
take care of the plane watch the plane
right get a new plane okay advertise
right advertise take care of my wife
buyers and Shannel invest in my business
right I'm doing all day long you know
and then and then what I'm trying to do
really is I'm trying to I'm trying to
put this money to use at some point okay
I operate with what's called what I call
is a 40% point I'm looking for 40%
to save on my income whatever it takes
how much money do I need to make so that
I have 40% that I could take over here
and shove a big giant piece of cake into
a deal
now the phenomenon about 40% is this
there's a point where it's impossible
for you to save 40% so so see I found I
had to get to around ten thousand
dollars a month in income to save for so
so I had to keep making this go up the
income is the only thing that restricts
how much money you can invest in safe so
that this is why the guy that says I'm
good how many of you have employees all
right I'm good making fifty or sixty
grand a year they'll never be motivated
because they're screwed up about money
they they have the wrong knowledge about
money
seventy-six percent of Americans live
paycheck to paycheck you can send them
to as many tony robbins seminars as you
want to you will not change the state of
a person indefinitely if they have money
problems every day it is impossible
because that contract every time I'm at
Whole Foods oh my god three uh what is
it grass grass fed beef is that much
money i contract the moment I say Oh God
[Music]
if you have to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple so it would be like a little
beacon pay believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]